hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday January 6 2020 or 2022 x' zero to
the two zero however the [__] you guys
are saying it what's going on how are
you I'm gonna start this podcast off
with an announcement all right the bill
Bert the bill Bert podcast is back all
right we're gonna have two episodes a
month it's me and Bert Kreischer two
episodes a month with video subscribe to
the podcasts on iTunes Spotify and
wherever podcasts are available also go
to the all things comedy youtube channel
and subscribe first clip is up this
wednesday first new episode drops next
Wednesday what first clip up is this
Wednesday first new episode drops next
Wednesday January 15th no that's right
cuz we've done - sorry yeah check it out
where me and Bart just hang out smoking
a cigar it's always some big giant
[__] up doctor cigar
I love Berk right sure and I think
you're gonna love him - alright let's
get on with the the unbelievable failure
that is bill burr already and I've
already talked of myself in the third
person so I've even failed even more I
it's I'm six days into a new decade and
I have continued behavior that I've been
trying to get rid of since at least I
don't think in the 90s I realized how
angry I was I'm in the 2000s this entire
century I have failed [__] miserably
you know I'm like that franchise that
gets a new [__] coach or a new
goddamn draft pick and and and the whole
fanbase gets excited and after one game
you like nah it's gonna be the exact
same [__] deal so [__]
disappointed in myself by the way did
you guys see that thing on ESPN on Ryan
Leaf Jesus Christ [__] brutal [__]
brutal I got Titan men like you know the
way you [__] people go off on people
I'm talking about all you P I'm not
talking about me you might see when I go
off on somebody it's an act
okay I'm just air quote joking I'm just
up there air-quote making money
air-quote being mean
dude the [__] I don't know I can't make
up my mind I started to watch it and I
fell asleep because it was late at night
but he cheek Ryan leaf goes through if
he gave you [__] old and you know
young sorry and you don't know Ryan Leaf
was drafted number two behind Peyton
Manning in 1998 the San Diego Chargers
as always as always just always picking
the right guy you know actually they do
pick the right guy and then they [__]
trade him away
considering they had Drew Brees Wow
they had Drew Brees never had a shot of
pink Manning because the cold suspect
for us anyways they picked this guy Ryan
Leaf right and six-foot-five [__] big
dude for the cannon-armed Washington
state all of this [__] and he won his
first two games and then had like the
worst game ever he could possibly have
as a QB just about him one completion in
a rainy game at Arrowhead Stadium in
Kansas City and I guess he lost all his
[__] confidence and there's this
classic video of him yelling at a
reporter just looking like a lunatic and
it was so I'm gonna use this expression
even though I don't even know what it
means
it was so apropos that he said never an
expression so many [__] times you
know how to use it but you don't really
know what it means does that mean
perfect for this situation a poignant or
this fits this that's what it means
right you know what's gonna be [__]
great I'm actually gonna try to actually
know how to spell that and look that up
what the [__] hey hey hey sandy what's
the name of the [__] lady in the in
the little vibrator speaker that you
talked to Siri hey Siri honey spill
apropos apropos
a pro PO apropos definition okay apropos
she remarked a propose of the initiative
it's not going to stop the abuse what
does that mean it's the right word what
is being relevant an opportune oh yeah
all right that's okay look at look at
look at 2020 I'd I know things it was so
perfect that I watched Ryan Leaf
completely imploding and losing his [__]
if you watch that thing where he yells
at that [__] reporter that was
basically basically me at the Apple
store yesterday some of my worst and
most embarrassing behavior as a human
being has happened in the Apple store I
hate that [__] store I [__] hate
that [__] company I hate Steve Jobs I
hate their round building i [__] hate
them and i buy all their products cuz
there's no way out
it's like those poor [__] people who
go to Dubai to get a construction job
and they confiscate is that you say
confiscate conference gate confiscate
your [__] passport and then you
become a slave I am a slave to that
[__] product I don't know how to
[__] get out of it if I get out of it
I literally cut myself off from three
quarters of [__] humanity I [__]
hate those people I hate that [__]
company don't they like pay a major fine
every year for their pollution to the
environment how they do this [__] Shh
I don't want to get going with this
[__] [__] so anyways I bought a
[__] laptop now laptop I bought I I
bought an iPad off the round [__] for
aviation purposes because they got this
new software that's [__] incredible
you know that I just want to make a have
a right on my [__] thigh some
and I know where the [__] everybody is
around me and it's [__] amazing
alright so anyways so there's one for
Apple and they created a [__] device
well actually they didn't they ripped
off a device somebody else came up with
the tablet first I don't [__] know so
all I want to do is Roma zoom zoom sorry
all I want to [__] is that song still in
my head all I want to do is go on the
[__] road and not bring my [__]
laptop which weighs 9,000 [__] pounds
even though it does it compared to the
old ones but in my world it does alright
this is just all it's just just the most
so [__] embarrassing right so I I
have this Olympus LS 100 and what I want
to do is I want to [__] record a
podcast and then upload it to my [__]
iPad and then just get on with my
streamlined life alright so I have the
little umbilical cord attachment you
know what I learned yesterday lightning
to USB attachment off of my [__]
laptop that I got like a year ago so
this year I buy one of the round [__]
[__] tablets I go to plug the
lightning to USB [__] goddamn thing
in and it just keeps spitting it out
like a baby not wanting to eat its food
and you know of course like a the dumb
bald freckled content I am do I do this
during the [__] I don't know I don't
know how many [__] weeks I had to go
do this where I wasn't going to the
airport in two hours I decide I'm gonna
do this the morning I'm gonna go to the
airport in the afternoon LAX by the way
right so it doesn't fit so what do I do
do I go well let me Dobby that's how
this company operates I do what this was
what I signed up with them they've been
doing this to me no I didn't do that I
flicked out like this was the first time
I are experienced this
kunti selfish greedy [__] behavior
from these [__] ad than that [__]
[__] [__] company right up there
with the cruise ships how they pull into
port and just leave the [__] thing
running could give a [__] about the
future of anybody so it spits it out and
I have a Tourette moment so my wife cuz
she's a saint she just goes you want to
just go over the apples too and just go
get the attachment you need oh no no no
no no no no oh what happened before that
we called I called up the [__] this
this bootleg Apple [__] place to see
if they haven't and of course I don't
know what it is that I want I'm going
like I got a yeah hey I have I got a I
got a I got a I have a I pad this is me
trying to explain [__] the star track
[__] from nowadays and I'm like I need
do you have that attachment where I can
plug like a [__] external DVD you
know right into it she's like I'm sorry
I don't have something for a TV that
just and I was like just forget I said
DVD forget I said that
the thing so I can plug in like I'm on a
podcast and I she said we don't I don't
just can you hang on a second she came
back I knew she had what I needed I just
didn't know what the word was for it and
she just kept saying we don't have it
and I just hung up on her I hung up on
her because I didn't know what the thing
that I use every twice a [__] week
was called so of course it wasn't my
fault it was her fault and I was saying
things like DVD player to a young person
which is like me saying butter churner
I'm trying out this butter churner and
in my [__] you know the flat thing
it's like it's like a laptop but it
doesn't have a keyboard but you can get
one except you have to have a password
and then you forget what that that thing
is and then you'll just wake up staring
at it knowing that you have all the
technology you need and you have no
[__] idea how to figure out how to
get the password for a [__] keyboard
do you
one of those things so that conversation
ended in failure and I just said [__] it
I'm just gonna bring this [__] thing
that me most of my anger had to do with
the fact that I was leaving my wife and
cake for a week so we end up going down
on the [__] Apple store in my laughs
tells me why don't you bring everything
that you need that you want to plug into
this [__] thing so I brought my
tablet I bought my external DVD probably
thinking like hey man why are you using
your external DVD it's like as I don't
know where to go to watch the movies
online I don't know okay I got some
screeners I wanted to watch that movie
19:17 they gave me a [__] DVD I have
an external DVD [__] thing I can
stick it in I could watch it on the
plane and enjoy myself right so I go
there and I talked to this poor bastard
who works there right
you know nice as hell I go how are you
sir how you doing he says great I said
listen and I brought the old [__]
thing that worked the old lightning to
[__] USB right which I learned when I
got there I go I need this he goes oh
you need a lightning to USB I go oh that
was what is called he says yes hey so he
says that's not a problem and I'm like
holy [__] I'm gonna walk into this store
I met one of the geniuses he's such a
genius he knows what this [__]
freckled dummy wants so we all walk over
to the wall by the way I brought in
everything in one of those like you know
those cloth things that you bring to the
grocery store so you don't use plastic
bags so they don't end up in the ocean
around some [__] poor fishes head or
up the nose of some turtle whatever the
[__] happens right so I got all my [__]
in there right so the guy goes over and
he goes yeah we have one of those and
I'm like oh my god it's gonna work out
it's finally Bill Byrne and Technology
are finally gonna have a good day right
and guys I know this is all my [__]
fault okay
I mean the polluting the environment
thing is on the round cuts but like I I
know that if I just took the [__]
time if I this if this [__] on any level
[__] interest me if I actually just
took the time
I could do this you have to understand
in my house I don't know how to use the
DVD player I don't know how to get to
Apple TV I don't know how to do anything
I just I yell upstairs I'm like Nia how
do I get the [__] she stomps down the
[__] stairs and she just does it for
me alright she's doing everything when
it comes to technology it's it's she
might as well just be like feeding meat
likes like soup
I don't know right so my thing is is
once I learn how to do something I
memorize it okay there's no
understanding it's just straight
memorization and then what happens is
some new system comes along or some new
[__] thing and then I have to learn
it all over again and then that's when
it goes off the rails
alright I [__] hate this [__] alright
I bought that [__] Prius okay in 2007
alright October 2007 so a little over 12
years ago guess what it still [__]
works I can still get in it push the
button it still turns on and still does
what the [__] it's supposed to do this
[__]
this Apple [__] doesn't this Apple [__]
works for 18 months okay and then it's
like you're putting out a disco record
in 1982 and wondering why it didn't get
on the charts that's what I [__] hate
you spent 3,000 to 3,500 wail and they
just chase it until it gets tired then
they bite its [__] tongue out and
they watch it [__] bleed to death
that's what it's like buying one of
these [__] things the second you get
it those [__] nerds and that round
building are working as fast as humanly
possible to make what the [__] you just
made
completely [__] useless so we go over
to the wall in the round [__] store
right and he's got yeah we got that we
got that and I'm like oh my god it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen and then
he's looking he's looking and he starts
making a face and I'm like oh no don't
do this to me so you know come on you
know it's like I'm a Chargers fan please
please pick the right guy please pick
the right guy in the draft please don't
[__] trade him away once you pick
them please right and he goes oh I know
we have I'm going to come on man you're
a huge store I know you have this I'm
trying to put good vibes out all right
well my entire being is going bill
just pack up your laptop pack up your
external DVD say goodbye to this nice
young man and just walk out of the store
because this [__] never [__] works
out for you and I'm like no don't pack
up because then you're putting it out to
the universe that this isn't gonna work
out alright so for three seconds I was
able to hold my temper while this guy is
now calling the back of the [__]
store to find the lightning to USB
[__] stupid thing that I need for my
[__] goddamn laptop and I mean sorry
for my tablet and I don't know I don't
really remember what happened next
I somehow just said I said I didn't
never fluttering to myself never [__]
[__] [__] fails I hate this
[__] thing you know people's you know
as they're looking at new tablets are
glancing over the shoulder like why what
is going on with this guy so I start
aggressively putting my my my [__]
iPad in boom threw that in the bag the
[__] DVD play don't put that in the
bag and I must have thrown something
else in the bank I don't know why I
picked the bag up and underneath my bag
unbeknownst to me was my cell phone ok
and the screen is now cracked in three
different [__] places
and writers I'm taking in trying to
figure out how the [__] it was like a
magic trick like how the [__] did my
[__] cell phone screen get cracked
like that correct as I'm taking in that
information because I didn't realize I'm
so mad in the moment that I just did
that I just picked the bag up when I was
like why the [__] is the screen all
cracked as I said that the Apple Genius
guy goes oh yeah we have one of those
cords in the back so now I got what I
wanted and I just created a new problem
I set off [__] it's guy just cracked my
[__] screen the guys like oh man I go
now I need a new phone right he goes
well we can fix the screen I go how
long's that take it goes there's no
telling today we're really busy I go I
got to be on a plane in two hours he
goes you want to get a new phone it's
like I don't want to get a new [__]
phone and then I'm just sitting there
and then the cord comes out and I'm just
going like yeah I and I literally say to
this poor kid I go you know what I go I
absolutely [__] hate this [__]
company I never have a good experience
when I'm getting mad at him because I
give I just waited another three [__]
seconds if I had just [__] waited I
wouldn't have been in this situation
right but that's not how I'm [__]
wired so I [__] actually went in
there they had what I needed I just
didn't have the [__] patience to wait
three [__] seconds and in the process
is a 51 year old man had a temper
tantrum at a mall at 51 it broke the
[__] screen of my cell phone in three
places before this kid went and got me
what the [__] I needed and I'm [__]
flipping out I wasn't yelling I was
[__] [__] [__] you
guys know you do I said do you know that
you guys played this [__] fight
against the [__] if I was just
looking at me
and he was so cool but I'm sorry man I'm
sorry it was the coolest dude ever there
was two other [__] people there
looking over at me whispering so I
[__] walk out with all this
technology in this [__] bag and my
busted cell phone with the cord that I
now need and I come walk it out my
wife's a with my kid and she's going did
they have what you need I said yes they
did and she's looking at me then why do
you have that look on your face it's
like oh cuz I smashed up my [__] cell
phone and then you know and then you
know I dropped an f-bomb and then my
little kid looks at me she goes dad dad
don't say that don't say that I go
you're right buddy you're right buddy
and then she starts giving me dad day
you have to be nice to people you can
that she starts giving me a lecture
right and I'm having to walk away from
my own daughter because I'm so [__]
mad
and I don't even know who at this point
and I don't want to be upset in front of
my kid you know and I'm at this [__]
mall where they've always play like Tony
Bennett and Sinatra like that's why
they're playing all these [__] songs
is I am [__] whispering cursing under
my breath walking by Santa's house that
they're slowly taking apart in the
Christmas tree that they haven't taken
down yet to get back in the [__] car
and I'm trying to find the humor of it
right so we get back to the house my
car's coming to pick me up in about 45
minutes and I take out my lightning to
USB I plug it in to my tablet it does
not spit it out like a toddler and I'm
thinking like okay at least I have this
I then plug in my Olympus 100 it shows
up nowhere I can't find it
so I look for finder to click on because
that's what I do on my laptop it shows
up nowhere I can't find it so now I have
to go on my [__] laptop and look up
how the [__] do you where the [__] is
the finder there's no information
meaning there is no finder on the and
and I call up and Ruth emili´s the nice
young man who does the show and I call
him up he goes hello
and I'm like Andrew I [__] how the
[__] do you [__] upload a [__]
[__] [__] a [__] [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__] podcast
and he's laughing God god bless him he
just starts laughing and he tried to
help me out and it didn't work and I had
to bring my laptop anyways and then I'm
going to the airport with my [__] I wish
I could take a [__] picture of my
[__] there's like three stars with
the spiderweb cracks each of them for
each piece of technology that I threw
back in the bag
one of them's the laptop one of them's
the external DVD and I don't know what
the last [__] thing was maybe one of
them bounced I have no [__] idea so
now I am in Memphis Tennessee with my
laptop and my cracked cell phone and I
have to go to the Apple store today and
I'm going in and my goal is just to walk
in there and just I guess basically just
try to maintain my [__] composure I
cannot I cannot [__] believe I am
this [__] old and this is a problem
that I have been working on since I
probably right I might probably I don't
know 33 or 34 is when I realized that I
had
good problem and I am like 20 years down
the [__] road almost and I had a
meltdown that I would have [__] had
and when I was thirty three zero
improvement you know like a [__]
franchise that just it just it's never
gonna make the [__] playoffs they're
never gonna do anything right they just
never gonna [__] get it unreal
I'm [__] real my apologies to that
kid who works in anybody else who heard
me at the [__] Apple store I wasn't
screaming I was just [__] [__]
[__] doing that like what the
[__] what the [__] is wrong with me so
that happened all right and I think if
I'm honest with myself it most of it had
to do now that's not I can't even blame
it on the fact that I was gonna be
missing my family this week on the road
it really wasn't that I would have done
that on a sunny [__] Saturday if I
just hit the [__] lottery I would
have done the same goddamn thing anyway
so there you go all right let's talk
let's talk sports here
I'm gonna go hockey first the Bruins
lost why do I write the Flyers we didn't
lose to the Flyers we lost to the
[__] Edmonton Oilers and I love the
Broads and I love this team but I gotta
tell you something I'm seeing the same
we have not solved the [__] problem
that caught that I feel caused us to
lose to the unbelievably less talented
st. Louis Blues which is we do not hold
anybody accountable when they take
liberties against our team that dude on
Edmonton Leon was a dry saddle Heloise
say his name was a [__] great player
he came out and on one of his first
shifts to the game he elbows Torey Krug
right in the side of the [__] head
Torey Krug the smallest guy in the team
and one of our best players he goes down
nobody goes over all right we don't have
a Sean Thornton we don't have a loot
cheats we don't have an Adam McQuaid
nobody goes over and holds this guy
accountable he goes off two minutes for
elbowing he gets out of the penalty box
he goes right back out on the ice and
face washes [__] Torey Krug again the
end of the play you know with a skirmish
in front he [__] does it again and
nobody grabbed that guy by the back of
his neck and beat him down to the [__]
ice to be like hey you're in the TD
Banknorth Garden you don't do that there
was nothing there was nothing and I I
just I don't know what we got to get
somebody I was hoping I don't know why I
was hoping that kid John Moore was gonna
do something like that cuz he just
that's just an old school name John
Moore you know his name isn't Dakota or
[__] and I don't know what the [__]
they call kids nowadays like all the rec
John Bob bill Mike like I still feel
like all those names are gone John Moore
that just sounds like some kid I would
have drank with outside you know in the
woods so I was hoping maybe he would do
something and I just nothing happened
and that's I I don't maybe I'm just an
old school hockey fan I just think that
that is gonna be a [__] problem
because other than that I love the team
I think we have like you know we have
two great lines and I think our third
line of fourth line that they're [__]
they all play well I'll get the puck on
the net all flying dang that's some
great young talent and all that I'm
really you know then I got this test
behind me I'm really [__] watching and
I'll tell you right now if you're a
[__] hockey fan I've said this before
that daily faceoff where they have like
the line combinations I mean you already
know your team you just put up the other
team's team and it's great because you
can kind of look to see if it's there
first
I mean they got a superstar like you
know you know McDavid or something like
that obviously you know that that's like
the first line but some of these others
shit-bomb team so you don't know anybody
on the [__] team you know or
everybody on that team is like from
[__] Finland or Russian so you can't
you can't tell one name from the other
daily face-off you click on line
combinations it's the best way it's the
best way to do it so anyway we went up
one to nothing and ended up losing the
game I think four to one I watched that
game in the morning and then I watched
my New England Patriots played the
Tennessee Titans at home in a fog and
the game that I kind of knew was coming
came and I was not surprised believe it
or not that we lost and it's just as
much as we couldn't stop the run I mean
that's the obvious sort of way of
looking at it but the reality was was
our defense spent so much time on the
[__] field this year with the you
know our receiving court just killing
drives and they just would double
edelman and then these other guys just
you know one of the great things about
Bill Belichick teams is I always feel
like you know a third round draft pick
plays like a second-round draft pick a
second-round draft pick plays like a
first-round draft pick everybody
elevates their game and this is one of
the first times I can remember where
that just didn't happen and I know it's
not well I don't know we've lost so many
coaches I feel like every [__]
another week we were playing somebody
I mean rabl was the coach of Tennessee
you know Matt Patricia's at [__]
Detroit Romeo criminal or whatever isn't
[__] Houston it says we're always
running in to somebody who used to be in
our band of brothers coaching staff over
there
I just feel like you know was a it was
just I don't know what for whatever
reason I'm sure that talented receivers
or whatever they just couldn't we just
didn't get on the same [__] page and
I was really surprised with the amount
of analysis to that they just kind of
missed that me go
Brady looks old a bloodless like he
can't get in a [__] rhythm going
three and out or maybe it one first down
and go and three and out it's like why
the [__] you would choose to look at him
like he was the [__] problem
you know our offensive line could have
been a little bit better I'm just saying
some of the [__] that people already
know but I just I don't know it was you
know it's always tough to see your team
lose but the upside is is I was really
afraid that we were gonna beat the
Titans and then this subpar team was
gonna limp into Kansas City and then
Kansas City was going to get their
revenge and they were gonna sit there
and talk [__] like they built beat a New
England Patriot team that we've come to
know and love if you me they didn't so I
love a first-round loss okay if my
team's gonna lose get me to to the back
of the head all right
don't [__] get me all the way the big
dance and then I have to sit there in
the longest [__] game of the year the
Super Bowl did you [__] see they have
JLo and Shakira not Shakira this year
JLo next year they have JLo and Shakira
how [__] long is this halftime show
gonna be there is no [__] way that
they did not squeeze in an extra
commercial [__] break I cannot
[__] believe the greed of the NFI
actually I can they don't give a [__] I
actually you want to hear a conspiracy
theory I have congratulations by the way
to the Tennessee Titans man you played a
great game and I'm very excited now to
just watch the playoffs my team's out of
it I don't have to die a thousand
[__] deaths on every [__] play I
can just sit there and enjoy
and I really like all the teams that are
left so I gotta be honest truth is
there's really no team that I [__]
hate anymore it's kind of weird so
anyway I have a here's my conspiracy
theory I think that the [__] prevent
defense they said this is a real this is
a [__] long one here people this is
like as far as like this is a high like
the amount of people that would have to
be involved I feel at one point when all
the NFL owners got together and said hey
man I know that we all share the same
sadness here is that we're all only
worth nine figures you know I mean every
day we have to deal with that were only
hundred millionaires right worth over a
hundred million dollars each and that's
something that that's a sadness that
only we can appreciate as owners of NFL
franchises and we need to do something
here so we can all become billionaires
or multi billionaires whatever the [__]
they were at I just think that they when
they were looking at their ratings which
is what we're they make their money
advertising and all that [__] TV
contracts so many [__] games were
over by the [__] mid third quarter
back in the day they were just the game
was [__] over and I just think they
were like what what is what is a way
that we could have games be the closest
they could possibly be for the longest
amount of time so fans are still
watching so the ratings don't drop off
in the fourth quarter or whatever and
that's when I think they went to the
coaches or when they came up with the
prevent defense and then no football
game was ever over you couldn't be up by
enough [__] points no matter what the
other team always had a [__] shot
that was that and then they just made
all of these [__] rule changes
where the the it's just like like the
amount of people looking at clowny when
he hit that [__] quarterback like
that was this dirty thing he should be
out of the [__] league and all of
that [__] is like that was just a
[__] hit back in the day alright and
these [__] quarterbacks have taken
advantage of the fact that they're
treated like the hot chick at the bar
then the amount of times that they
pretend to [__] slide and then
continue to run for another seven yards
because the defensive back or the
linebacker pulled up because he doesn't
want to get a flag and they take
advantage of that [__] I had no problem
with that [__] hit granted I didn't
have to take the hit but it's like if
you're gonna start running down the
field like a [__] quarterback and
you're not gonna give yourself up and
you're gonna dive forward then that's
gonna [__] happen they maybe didn't
have to go after his head it did kind of
look like a little bit like a spear or
whatever but like I don't know some of
these [__] guys I mean that [__]
hit there back in the day that that just
would have been on NFL Films weina weina
where I remember that [__] song and
they would just talk about how [__]
the quarterback took a hit and here's
another thing - that that quarterback
wouldn't have left the game they didn't
have this little Cub Scout tent that you
went into back in the day when somebody
hit you like that they went out they got
the smelling salts and they said a [__]
oh we got the ball back you ready to go
back in any be like yeah yeah he is
[__] would go back in and you'd walk
into the defensive huddle they would
push you out you'd go back and going to
the right huddle that would be it
so anyway my Super Bowl picks are still
alive
sneaky Pete Carroll in your Seattle
Seahawks some of the biggest cheaters in
the NFL who never gets [__] for it you
want steroids you want to [__]
stadium that makes their
and sound loud whatever the [__] you you
want practicing with pads before you're
supposed to be probably would have a
[__] rule they can break up there and
Seattle I guess everybody feels bad
because it always rains up there so they
don't pay attention
[__] performance-enhancing drugs this
team was trying to steal signs that's
way worse because they win anyways the
Seattle Seahawks that's my pick that's
my pick to win the Superbowl I think
that they're gonna go into Green Bay and
I think old sneaky Pete Carroll is a
better coach than whoever the [__]
coaches the goddamn Green Bay Packers I
don't even know who the [__] it is I
know they got Aaron Rodgers but I don't
know that they have enough people even
remotely at that guy stratosphere as a
[__] player I don't know anything
about him I just said in November that I
thought that the [__] Seahawks were
gonna win so I have to stick with it and
I have to [__] sit here and say that
the [__] Seattle Seahawks are gonna
go into Lambeau Field alright and it's
gonna be like 90 below zero when they go
in there but once all those Wisconsin
fatties get in there and all that
blubber starts rubbing together as they
try to [__] squeeze their way into
their seats
I think game time temperature is going
to be just below freezing alright and I
think that they got they got Russell
Wilson they got cloudy they got [__]
you know what I'm loving too is they
brought back what's-his-face their beast
mode all right which has reminded me of
when the Patriots had Corey Dillon and
everybody thought Corey Dillon was old
or whatever and he was one of the major
reasons we won the Super Bowl that year
Marshawn Lynch I think that he is gonna
be you know he might be older but I
think he's just young enough where he's
gonna make a [__] difference I'm
hoping Jesus Christ to make him a lot of
goddamn know he's out there
the room-service here so I'm sticking
with them Minnesota Vikings first the
New Orleans Saints I mean Jesus Christ
how much sage do they need to burn
before those two teams meet each other
in the [__] playoffs but you can't
say that because the same
did win a Super Bowl so I feel like the
monkey is off their back
I [__] love drew brees I Love New
Orleans
I love the Saints I love that what are
the mercedes-benz one of the Superdome I
love that venue I love that I'm doing
two shows there Thursday and Friday
I [__] love everything about New
Orleans I just love that [__] place
and you know but back in the day too I
also loved the Minnesota Vikings the
purple people eaters and their fans have
suffered so that was a tough one because
I really like both of those teams and I
like both their fan bases and I don't
know man
it's just a [__] shame somebody's got
a [__] loose Vikings win that [__]
game did anybody see Nick swardson's
video you got to see it on Twitter when
the Vikings won is [__] that guy
makes me [__] laugh like nobody it's
just a quick video of him celebrating
and he's a [__] lunatic sports fan so
that made me happy for the Vikings
goddamn Saints man that was the one when
I was thinking like [__] I picked this I
picked the [__] Seattle Seahawks and
I forgot about the New Orleans Saints
the Vikings go in there then go into the
prevent defense right they had the game
won they were up by three points they
went to the prevent defense I got a good
idea let's go into a prevent defense
against droopy Drew Brees gee do you
think he's gonna pick us apart and go
right down the feat he only needs three
points at that point why don't you just
roll the [__] dice and just play
defense the same [__] defense that
made you go up by three points rather
than just giving yourself up all the way
down the [__] field you got drew
[__] Brees he's gonna get he gets the
[__] ball Oh out on the 25-yard line
and he's got to get to your thirty
before what he's in field never in field
goal [__] range I don't I know [__]
happen I know that [__] field goal
kicker you know he didn't miss one all
year and he missed well gives a [__] I
know some other things happened in that
game I don't give a [__] I know that
they [__] returned to goddamn a
fumble for a touchdown
turned out that the guy was on the
ground I know that that [__] guy
pushed off at the end of the game and he
did he did [__] push off they've
gotten [__] two years in a row is it
because their coach were the the Goodell
clown shirt the barstool clown shirt
that they're not getting a [__] and
he calls I don't know what it is I have
no idea by the way did anybody see I
don't think I brought this up did
anybody see Kevin Garnett on Bill
Simmons podcast when he was talking
about the Celtics going down to play the
Miami Heat and said that we weren't that
Celtics were not part of the NBA's
agenda I'm telling you I think all of
these [__] specifically basketball I
think is fixed not fixed straight up
like we're fixing games like that
mobbed-up ref who fix games in the NBA I
just think it is it is manipulated as
much as humanly possible what teams they
want to go into the finals the ones that
are going to get the biggest ratings the
fact that they allow these super teams
and all of that [__] it's just like it's
like watching a [__] reality show and
there is just a rule that the Lakers can
only suck for so [__] long I don't
know Posey brought up a great conspiracy
theory is the reason why last year when
the Saints did not get you know the pass
interference call was because la is such
a huge [__] media market and the NFL
for Dury for whatever reason has just
failed miserably in that city and they
needed to build excitement that Los
Angeles is old girlfriend their ex-wife
the person that they got out of their
life they were getting back together
with they had to get some excitement
going again
I know these conspiracy theories are
crazy but I stand by the one in NBA hope
I mean the NBA I mean it's the most this
the easiest game ever to fix it's the
only game with a [__] ref can just
take stars out of the game by giving
them two quick fouls to start the
[__] game you can't sit Brady you
know you can't sit
I guess Connor McDavid you could put
them in the box for [__] two minutes
but I don't know you get fouls on you
get two three [__] fouls you they you
don't see the guy for another quarter
all right bill shut up okay I will who
else the [__] Buffalo Bills you know
what are the people of Buffalo do to
deserve yet another game like that they
finally got a field goal kicker that
guy's out there [__] crushing it
hitting 40-something yarders whatever
they're on the upswing they're on the
upswing and I love their quarterback and
I think that they're gonna do great
things and I don't know if Tom Brady's
coming back next year but you know
within the next couple of years I mean I
mean who knows what that guy is he gonna
play police 50
I don't know but assuming he's going to
age like a normal person and he's gone
now or next year or whatever like the
AFC East is going to go back to where
the [__] it was before the Patriots
started their run which was this guy I
feel is gonna go back into the hands of
the Buffalo Bills and maybe just maybe
with parity and all of that [__] by
the way if one more person sends me a
tweet I hate getting going is it just me
or does the guy who coach the coaches
the bills look like bill burr it's not
the joke it's that joke structure please
people it's 20 20 please stop using the
prefix is it just me that's right up
there with I know what you're thinking
why did George Bush [__] Ruth Buzzi you
know that was like the classic hacky
comedian joke when you go up on stage to
say somebody that you look like you know
why I know what you're thinking that why
do why does this guy look like Ron
Howard
the age you know is always that you know
is it just me or blunt I always hate it
is it just me because I always felt like
clever comics would use that you know is
it just am I the only one who thought
this brilliant analogy
having said that yeah I think me and
that guy do look a lot alike
I feel like that that guy is losing in
the comparison because he's I don't know
he's I'd say he's a little
better-looking and he also coaches a
professional football team so he's
winning on both sides and I think he's
doing a hell of a job out there and the
AFC East is going to be there sooner
rather than later
what's that quarter is it Josh Allen I
don't know who the [__] it is but um I
don't know I think I think they got I
think they got I think they the first
legit [__] dude since Jim Kelly so I
think that's it I don't know I I was too
busy running around trying to do family
[__] and then to get a lightning to USB
to watch any of those [__] football
games in their entirety what was the
early NFC game well if I wait like they
had the Saints versus the [__]
Vikings the Vikings win and then what
was the other game although Seattle
versus the [__] Eagles the Eagles the
Buffalo Bills of the [__] NFC I can't
say that I shouldn't say that because
they also want to [__] Superbowl so
the monkeys off their back too and they
beat my team so I should shut the [__]
up all right there you go there's your
NFL playoffs so next week next week oh
my god did I do 48 [__] I haven't
done having me read any goddamn
advertisements or anything like that yet
well gives a [__] who gives a [__]
well you guys you don't listen to this
thing for the [__] advertising do you
all right NFL playoffs schedule
lightning to USB all right the Vikings
are going into not even San Francisco
not even San Jose this
and something or other wherever the [__]
this stadium is to play the San
Francisco 49ers now who are the 49ers
are the 49ers the team you saw for the
whole year that up until December when
they started giving up 30 40 points a
game until the last game of the year
when they really needed to buckle down
and they shut down the [__] Seattle
Seahawks
who the [__] are they I don't know a lot
of people are high in the 49ers I don't
[__] know I don't know I don't I
don't know who they are
the Chiefs first the Texans that's gonna
be a great [__] game
JJ Watts hold down the [__] defense
they got a great quarterback
- Shaun Watson you know against Patrick
my Holmes
you know I I need more State Farm
commercials by the way Jesus Christ
you like the 58 of them all right let's
go of my picks I'm gonna go the obvious
here 49ers beat the Vikings and I think
the Chiefs weren't a real close one I
don't like that defense but I do like
them at home all right
Ravens first the Titans that's an easy
one and then I got sneaky pete carroll
going into [__] green bay right with
the place where the [__] fondue
fountain was born you know what what a
great thing to have you [__] state be
all about cheese you know it's kind of
funny to look at it but when you really
think about it I mean who doesn't like
cheese well I guess people with [__]
sickle-cell whatever the [__] whatever
lactose intolerance they don't like it
well you know what they do like it they
like it so much that they [__] get
this do they get the tummy ache but will
you shut up I just read the
advertisement all right here we go
Bruins my Bruins my Boston Bruins got
the [__] New Jersey Devils um so I
haven't watched this much hot much
hockey since last year's playoffs I'm
loving that I'm back into it during the
regular season loving that I have the
[__] time
to do it all right what do we got here
all right oh look who's back old zip
talk about how challenging hiring is
well you know what I don't really run a
business so I don't know how to [__]
do and and how I got in with emili´s was
he walked up to me and said like in the
end of the 2000s and was like hey man I
really like your podcast I think I could
make it sound better and I was like okay
Jesus is the worst I had read everything
I imagined if I ran a business hiring
would be difficult you know cuz it's
just like alright I don't know anything
about this guy is this guy cool or is he
gonna come in here and [__] shoot up
the play oh I can't I can't I gonna have
to erase them Hey look who's back it's
old zip recruiter talk about how
challenging hiring is well yeah what are
you a mind reader you know how do you
get the good people how do you go out
and find him you just gonna stick a sign
out there and now hiring and any animal
off the street can come walking in
that's not the way to do it it's not how
the NFL Draft works you don't just go
hey we need some new people to play on
the team show up at the stadium this
Wednesday at 1:00 o'clock you don't you
go to New York you go to the [__]
draft well zip recruiters the NFL draft
of hiring [__] regular people who
can't catch a ball but could actually do
a job in accounting all right zip
recruiter makes it easy work in the URL
once at the beginning zip recruited comm
slash burn why did they I don't
understand why this isn't edit okay is
that is that a URL URL is that
enlightening to you our URL zip
recruited our comm / / ID zip me
lacunae signs sends your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of job resumes to find people
with the right experience and invite
them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip and analyzes
each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match again ziba
is so effective that four out of five of
the employees who post on zip get a
quality candidate through the site
within the first day and right now my
listeners could try zip recruiter for
free at this exclusive web address zip
recruited comm / / that zip recruiter
dot-com / BER spell upper B you are our
zip dot-com / / alright tip recruited
the smartest way to attire okay
brave this company is called brave oh my
god is this about a female comic talking
about her vagina that was so brave
they're so courageous they're just
breaking down walls guys got to talk
about that [__] dick chef
alright brave everybody brave is the web
browser reimagined keeping your personal
information private as you surf the web
people you are living in this in the
surveillance economy every time you
download a web page you are not just
downloading the content text and images
you are also downloading privacy
invading trackers many people many
popular media sites have over 100
trackers on every page you're being
profiled and tracked across the web so
what you might say wait until you hear
what information about you is shared
your digital profile can include your in
sexual orientation political views
religious beliefs or even what type of
medical issues you might have it
includes what you are reading watching
and listening to thinking of all this
[__] I look at it includes your location
sometimes right up to your exact GPS
coordinates what is wrong with people
why what are they why are they so
[__] information is king and it
includes unique ID codes that are as
specific to you as is your social
security number cell so that all of this
data can be tied to you continually over
time this allows companies you've never
heard of to maintain intimate profiles
about you and what makes you tick and on
everyone and on everyone you know data
collected about you can be used to
manipulate your decisions but also
countrywide decisions like elections
what why does the government allow all I
know why cuz because politicians are
underpaid that's why and then they
probably pay these corporations for that
information if I wear this tie it's
gonna make this most the most people
vote for me and the kicker is you're
paying for it downloading the
surveillance economy costs you money and
extra data charges it slows down page
load times by an average of 5 seconds
per page and it drains your battery life
but there is a way to protect yourself
and remove this surveillance economy
start by using brave brave stops data
grabbing trackers in creepy ads from
following you across the way I'm
actually going to use this which allows
you to browse up to 6 times faster with
other browsers switching to brave is
easy but how do I know you're not one of
those guys and I'm going to open up to
go positive switching to brave is easy
and import your bookmarks with one click
and in less than 60 seconds you'll be
enjoying a better internet it's free and
your all your Chrome extensions work in
brave I don't know what that means
listeners of the part
Cass can switch to brave for free today
go to brave dot-com slash BER and
download brave today that's brave
dot-com slash burner and switch today J
says what kind of [__] world do we
live in alright stamps.com everybody
let's face it most New Year's
resolutions are hard to keep smash cut
bill burr in an Apple Store get more
exercise save more money don't [__]
lose your [__] in an Apple Store well I
have a resolution that's easy to keep
stop wasting time going to the post
office and use stamps calm instead with
stamps calm you can do anything you do
at the post office right from your
computer
well you can't mingle with strangers as
you stand in a ridiculously long line
plus stamps calm gives you something you
can't get at the post office big
discounts on postage whether you're a
small office sending invoices an online
seller shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps comb can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your email once
your mail is ready just hand it to your
mail carrier or drop it in a mailbox
it's that simple with stamps calm you
get five cents off every first-class
stamp and up to 40% off Priority Mail
stamps calm is a no-brainer saving you
time and money it's no wonder over 700
thousand small businesses already use
stamps calm so give yourself a
resolution you can actually keep this
year stop going to the post office and
go to stamps.com instead there's no risk
and with my promo code Burpee URR
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus free postage and
digital scale no long term commitments a
contract guys go to stamps icon click on
the microphone top of the homepage Jesus
Christ how [__] long is this and type
in bur that stamps com promo code bar
stamps com never go to the post office
again all right we got time for a couple
of reads here estrogen in the impossible
burger all right somebody's given
goodness go do the other side now for
those who didn't listen to last
Podcast somebody wrote and told me the
impossible burger has like nine I don't
know how much [__] how much estrogen
in it to the point literally that a man
would start lactating which my wife
laughed at said a man cannot lactate all
right hey Billy burger tits heard that
guy email you about estrogen and soy
he's repeating some YouTube [__]
that has been debunked time and time
again with some pretty basic science the
estrogen he talked about our plant
estrogens they don't act at all like
human estrogens and they won't impact
your testosterone at all see this is why
I hate the food industry I don't know
who to believe is this coming from some
[__] person an impossible burger is
the other person right is this person
right I don't know consider this Japan
has the highest consumption of soy in
the world but lower rates of estrogen
facilitated breast cancer okay does that
mean it's because it's soy consider this
[__] way also considered that cow's milk
is literally hormone filled for the
purpose of helping calves grow yet
people have no problem eating that [__]
while drinking it yeah below is a link
from the Mayo Clinic going more in depth
okay all right I'll post this link all
right hey Bill men can lactate hey old
Billy milk shooters
I love the podcast love the company's
cetera et cetera so this email is in
regards to last Monday's podcast during
which you and Nia were talking about the
impossible burger I'm not a hundred
percent certain about the science
surrounding the fake burger but I do
know that men can lactate Nia seemed
adamant to the contrary which is common
pose for her when she's triggered by
people who annoy her I'll shut the [__]
up and it's not with me or with you you
sound triggered by her she becomes
sanctimonious yells obscenities at the
person she's annoyed with or maybe she's
just trying to be funny and then creates
on the fly facts to make herself appear
virtuous Wow
you got issues huh and what do I do what
the [__] do i do my bite better are you
better which by the way makes her great
to listen to on the podcast
oh you passive-aggressive [__] anyways
here's basic lack tations back to basic
lactation 101 I thought it was lactation
she was going to talk about both male
boobs for both men and women breast
tissue contains hollow cavities called
oh god I can't read this [__] alveoli
pronounced
alveoli alveoli sorry which are lined
with milk secreting cells the critical
determination of lactation is a hormone
called prolactin which is most commonly
produced by females during the milk
production phase known as Galacta fo
Lisa's I love how this person wrote all
the [__] sound spelling of this it
kind of killed the comedy of me trying
to [__] pronounce it but here we go
no non pregnant women generally have
double the amount of prolactin
circulating in their bodies than men
which then spikes tenfold for them
during and after pregnancy so yes
Tania's point females are wired to
lactate based on their body's response
to pregnancy but she was completely
wrong when she stated unequivocally dude
we get it you're smart unequivocally
causing her to appear virtuous as she
sanctimonious sanctimonious is a hack
word by the way now that everybody's
been politicized on [__] social media
all right so is politicized bill alright
fair enough okay but Baba but she is
completely wrong okay wait so yes
Tania's point females are well to let
wired to lactate based on their body's
response to privacy but she was
completely wrong when she stated
unequivocally who uses that word that
men can lactate
that's like did anybody
says unequivocally also says
matriculated when they talk about their
second stint in college I did my
undergrad here then matriculated oh wow
how many syllables are in that word we
can apps we absolutely can our bodies
are equipped and ready to do so under
extraordinary circumstances especially
if those circumstances include a drastic
boot boost in estrogen levels if the
impossible burgers study from last week
has any truth to it then it can cause
men to grow breasts and then secrete
milk pronounced milk that's funny so to
all men out there who identify as milk
producers don't listen to Nia strap on
those breast pumps and live your [__]
tit truth thanks Bill and go [__]
yourself all right next here we go so it
is possible well I'll have to call her
up and use words like sanctimonious and
unequivocally no meat at them get the
Golden Globes dear Billy beat me I love
beets I went to Australia and fell in
love with that is it a vegetable it's a
root vegetable bill it's unequivocally a
sanctimonious [__] root vegetable
all right big fan of the podcast but get
Nia back on the show where she belongs I
know we got a kid what are we gonna do
you had recently given the Golden Globes
praised for sticking to their guns by
not nominating any women out of fear for
getting me to know that's not why I did
it I just did it because it was funny
that women were complaining about it I
thought it was hilarious that adults
give a [__] about winning a [__]
trophy there's something unbelievably
childish about it and my favorite
[__] thing ever is when somebody with
their own TV show wins a [__] trophy
and they still start crying talking
about how difficult their life is it's
like what more good [__] has to happen
to you I still have to sit here and
listen to your pain um anyway however it
was just announced today that they will
not serve meat on the menu
during the Golden Globes dinner their
rationale was as follow follows the feet
will be the feast will be plant-based a
decision made by the Hollywood Foreign
Press Association out of concern for
global warming well yeah all the cows
are out there farting out of all this
[__] Hollywood does to [__] with the
planet props in the ocean I know right
blowing up [__] oh yeah all the water
bottles on set wearing clothes one
[__] time and then and then throwing
it out this screams is a big publicity
stunt well this is the thing about
Hollywood is I don't think you'll ever
find a group of people that is more up
their own ass and just feels that
they're smarter then you I would even go
beyond like people in DC they're just
pure [__] evil
DC's just pure [__] evil and then
Hollywood is a reaction to DC where they
all just think they're so smart they all
have it figured there's like there's
literally like people who host reality
shows if you follow them on Twitter
they're like they like feel that they
can solve the world's problems and then
they actually consider running for
office and then the [__] regular guy
going down the street is so [__] dumb
that they actually vote from the amount
of [__] actors that have held office
it's just I don't know anyways how much
[__] but then again
Al Franken was great I think
Schwarzenegger did a great job too I
mean you might not agree with what the
[__] is his politics are but I mean I
don't know I think that's kind of like
when you see like someone who isn't an
actor do a good job acting and then you
see an actor do a good job as the
politicians like I think if you kind of
it basically a smart person and you
apply yourself you know it's not like
you have to like you're tone deaf and
you have to go sing you know what I mean
you just have to [__] do a job show
up surround yourself with Toyland
talented please shut up bill all right
sorry all right anyways out of all the
[__] that Hollywood does I remember that
this screams is a big
Blissett e stun 11 chefs 120 culinary
staff 50 bartenders 160 stewards and 250
servers how much [__] car exhaust
will it take tit for all of those [__]
to get there I love this email I firmly
believe any social responsibility from
corporations it's a bunch of [__]
case in point yeah exactly I agree with
you hundred percent evidently they will
be serving chilled golden beet soup
topped with shaved candy-striped beets
and pistachio King oyster mushroom
scallops and wild sorry air-quote
scallops I guess they're gonna be fake
scallops and wild mushroom risotto and
vegan opera dome dessert anyways after
your impossible meat rant last week I
did not have a rant last week I read
somebody else's [__] don't put that on
me I thought you'd find that
entertaining and I would love to hear
your thoughts happy New Year to you
Nia and the little one best regards from
Boston yeah listen I'm not gonna lie to
you I [__] love Los Angeles I love
show business it's why I'm [__] in it
but you know the same way when I watch
sports where it's like you know if my
team commits past interference I'm not
someone who says it wasn't pass
interference
III don't take it to that [__] level
you know what I mean I do defend the
Patriots when people say that they're
cheaters when there's you know you have
like the like most like pathetic [__]
stealing signs in letting air out of a
ball is got to be two of the saddest
[__] attempts ever while other teams
are doing steroids and all this other
[__] [__] then you're looking past
them that's the only thing but you know
if you're gonna sit there and say the
[__] tuck rule is [__] 100% I
agree it's a stupid [__] rule but
it's not the Patriots fault that they
came up with that [__] rule but you
know I don't know what do you know that
year well then Steelers when they said
that that was caught the ball and scored
a touchdown they said it wasn't a
[__] catch that was [__] the
Steelers should've won I can [__] do
that same way
Hollywood okay there's a bunch of
amazing [__] people in the business
that I'm in but they're not the ones
that get the attention it's the [__]
preachy [__] people that are I don't
know they're out there telling people
how to live their lives and and and and
and that type of [__] they seem to be
the ones that get all of the [__]
press or whatever so anyway one of the
things that I do love is that my wife
does watch award shows because I always
end up getting a bit out of it it's just
the it's the most self-involved [__]
thing I you did a good job acting we
want to give you a trophy it's the
funniest fun I don't understand and then
like as much as everybody makes fun of
Hollywood all of you [__] [__]
have have followed suit if you're in
sales they have the salesman award the
the best liar two old people who took
their pension they all have them you all
have your stupid [__] awards and I
bet people go up and cry at those
[__] things too it's just what it
really should be is it should be a way
to weed out sociopaths from a [__]
from a society I don't know what I what
the who the [__] I might have [__]
talked about that [__] um anyway I think
I'll be honest with you I don't [__]
hate those things there's been a couple
of times that uh actually you know what
I'm completely full of [__] because
there's been a couple of times
somebody's given me something and then I
went up there and had to talk about
stuff and then you actually start
thinking about why you went into this
[__] business and it does get a
little emotional it's [__] weird
maybe that's what it is maybe that's why
I don't like award shows is I don't
wanna be that guy going up there and
getting emotional I think that's what it
is oh my god I figured it out it's not
it's not the award shows problem it's my
problem
if you ever win anything you got to go
to the you got to go the Joe Pesci way
you know when he wanted for Goodfellas
he goes it was an honor thank you and
walked away that's the way you do it you
don't start talking because then you're
gonna start thinking about getting
bullied as a kid and you're just gonna
lose all [__] composure and make a
complete [__] ass of yourself but I do
stand by the fact that to go up there
and start spewing out your stupid
political ideologies that [__] like like
you're actually changing somebody's
opinion like you know I used to think
this way about the environment and then
the third lead on full house went up
there and [__] you know while they
were holding an award just changed my
opinion and I've never voted the same
way in an election since all right
election technology hey there Billy
ballot box that's another good one you
guys see a endless endless with these
things I just read a terrifying article
and I thought I'd share it with you oh
thank you
let me get you're gonna share with me
and there's gonna be no solution this is
why I don't watch the news hey here's
something horrific that's gonna happen
if we keep doing this and there's no
solution have a nice evening
all right and don't worry I have no
solutions look at that right there
basically there's this technology firm
that is vying for unlimited access to
our voting systems it's a private firm
founded on foreign soil and as a board
of directors that is comprised of former
CIA and Israeli intelligence the only
way I can look at this [__] and remain
calm is I just have to look at this like
these people are dealing with global
warming and the population problem on a
level that none of us can emotionally
handle and they just have to take over
everything maybe that's what it is I
don't know what it is I just tell jokes
I tell dick jokes and I do a podcast and
I watch sports that's what I do all
right I stay out of this whole [__]
world all right
I can't watch the leader of our country
assassinate someone from another country
while simultaneously saying I'm doing
this to prevent a war and actually have
people sit there and be like yeah man
that makes sense how many [__] times
Democrat a Republican can you see a
president in trouble and then their
immediate next [__] move to get this
[__] off of them is that they bomb
somebody
I mean Clinton did it trying to get out
of getting caught for getting a [__]
[__]
he dropped bombs on another [__]
country and this guy you know it kills
me is he can sleep at night that's the
kind of sick human being that becomes
president drone bombing weddings killing
kids these are not sane people but I've
never had to do the job so maybe you
know it takes a strong person to do
something like I have no idea any ways
when you start reading about what this
company and group is and the groups it's
done work with ie governments and
security firms you start to wonder why
we the American people would ever want
all of this information going to people
who use to use it to figure out how to
control us well they've always
controlled us on some level they always
have it's just there the technology is
just it's the control is getting a
little tighter that's all it's the same
principle as the save e save [__] [__]
cards from walgreens but then again we
the American people haven't been briefed
on this by our representatives and won't
be until it's a problem can we please
stop electing people the television
tells us about no you would have to have
like I so recently saw there was some
Democrat that was going like you know I
like the environment I think Americans
are good people he said all this [__]
that I believe him
and I was really behind the guy until
again when he said that he was going to
change it and it's like okay you know I
don't see a [__] weapon in your hand
I mean it would take a full-on [__]
revolutions to turn
of revolutions turn this [__] thing
or the level of bloodshed that would
have to happen to turn this [__]
thing around I don't know
hey here's one you'll never hear god
bless
the CIA and the Israeli intelligence god
bless them I hope you know as much as
what they're gonna do is going to be
[__] up maybe or maybe not I don't
know those people have to live with
whatever information they actually have
to sit there and read that [__] do you
remember do you ever watch true
detective the first season and do you
remember when Woody Harrelson's
character looked at the video of
whatever that person was doing to that
child and he does whoa just [__] lost
this [__] like there's people out there
trying to make the world a better place
and they have to watch [__] like that
and then somehow go to their family and
try to home to their family since it's
so there is the other side of that and
that's the only way to [__] look at
this [__] are all she gonna lose your
mind you know because what what I'm
gonna click on this [__] link and I'm
gonna read about this [__] and it's
gonna freak me the [__] out and make me
think about my kid and my wife and and
forget fellow Americans just fellow
human beings and it's just gonna just
ruin whatever amount of life I have left
I mean I can't
human beings are unbelievably flawed
okay and I am a prime example of it and
I would have no [__] idea how to try
and control them alright and I gotta
admit for as much negativity that is out
there right now it is pretty amazing
that we're able to get along as little
as we do you know I saw this [__]
article about the [__] that's going on
in like Venezuela and they were showing
all this stuff since the failed coup
down there and all of that and I don't
know I just wish stillness and every
single - you know these kids starve
to death from malnutrition and once
again the United States with economic
[__] sanctions the fact that they
have to [__] play a game like that
knowing that you know as a president
okay we're gonna put economic sanctions
and you know that you do that and you
have kids of your own and you know by
doing that that a kid is a parent his
parents are gonna watch their kid starve
to death I I just I don't know I don't
have a solution
I don't know how anything gets better
but it's just like there has to be a
[__] way as an individual that you
can Spock and just kind of live in your
own little thing where you just go out
and try to help a person in your country
or whatever but like this just the fact
that that [__] is going down the fact
that we're not living in harmony with
nature we're actually fighting it
thinking we're gonna win with our
sandbags to hold back the ocean you know
I don't know I don't well I guess in a
way we are using nature with the goop in
the ground but you just think you why
don't we use the wind in the Sun more so
hopefully we'll do that I don't [__]
know see this is why I don't read this
[__] because it sends me down this
[__] road all right let's do one over
eight and under eight it and then we're
gonna wrap this [__] up over eight and
underrated overrated you talking about
your lint or burger without us giving
the [__] without giving us the
[__] recipe no I'm swell you know
what I it's it's on its online but I I I
gotta be honest with you it is one of
the saddest things you could ever eat I
immediately thought about wallpaper and
wallpaper paste when I was trying to
think about what it tastes like but it
is you know if you eat it without a bun
and don't put any salt on it your
stomach your Tumtum will go down all
right
underrated eating what makes you feel
good I'm in great shape eating normally
at this point my life I'm looking and
feeling better than when I was worried
about egg yolks and all the other bad
info the 2000s gave us yeah speaking of
which I'm gonna go hit the gym right now
I got some I get you know I get some
[__] holiday poundage I need to get
rid of in Rose Bowl wait I need to
[__] drop all right here's to a great
year here's to a great decade and
everybody there's a lot of [__]
depressing [__] out there all right I
don't know I'm trying to live this life
right now where I don't watch the
[__] news at all and I try to go
directly to people that need help and I
try to do something like that's my new
thing and I'm probably not doing it
enough and I could get better at it
so that's what I'm gonna try to do in
response to the CIA and Israeli
intelligence and [__] all these
people trying to spy on everybody and
take more for themselves and everything
I think that's a very positive thing you
can do and yeah just you know try to be
a nice person don't be a [__]
all right go [__] yourselves everybody
I'll talk to you on on Thursday I'll
check you know and your go Bruins go
Celtics go [__] yourself